tout l'été c'est ce décor paisible de
l'estrie qui a servi de bureau à antoine
clément
il s'apprête à retourner à new york où
il habite avec sa conjointe
après deux mois de télétravail sa passe
est trop vite
travailler chez soi dans un appartement
à new york pour travailler à la campagne
au québec
je pense que je souhaite c'est simple ou
on peut travailler dehors les connexions
internet ici sont excellentes en fait
fait les pichette et sa conjointe sont
ceux qui ont loué à antoine il possède
six chalets à alfred tous complets ces
jours ci est très recherché pour les six
mois à venir
je reçois les appels à tous les jours de
personnes désespérées qui cherchent un
chalet parce que vous avez de la
disponibilité en septembre on est
complètement complet pour le mot
septembre le mois d'octobre est presque
complet novembre mais à moitié plein
noël est complètement bouquet la semaine
de relâche ça commence à se remplir
aussi les astres sont alignés pour ceux
qui louent des chalets complexité de
voyager crainte de l'hôtel volonté de
s'isoler ou comme pour antoine
découverte du télétravail tous des
facteurs pour expliquer la popularité
des locations je dirais que prenant au
moins une location sur 3 contient une
partie de télétravail il loue ses
chalets 10 à 15 % plus cher que l'an
passé et pour une durée minimum d'une
semaine
comme beaucoup d'autres propriétaires
question de s'ajuster à la demande est
aussi de réduire le nombre de
désinfection des lieux obligatoire entre
chaque réservation
ces frais de ménage ont aussi augmenté
de 50 dollars dany papineau dirige la
plateforme de réservation we shall
est.com quelque 575 propriété ils sont
inscrits actuellement elles étaient 400
au début de l'année son site web est
très consulté ce qu'on va marquer
beaucoup de gens qui se sont pris trop à
dernière minute pour louer un chalet cet
été est là pour l'ess pour l'automne
hiver on remarque il ya certaines
personnes se mettent à bouquet beaucoup
l avance en fait cette semaine une
réservation pour le mode ou l'année
prochaine un mois complet pour 5000
dollars
les meilleurs
or quelle était pris par te vite dit il
surtout pour des périodes comme la
relâche faut vraiment s'y prendre à
l'avancé trois mois présentement ce même
pas assez si quasiment ainsi mode avance
tout ce qui est alentours de moins deux
heures de montréal c'est quand même très
prisé donc les laurentides lanaudière
outaouais puis l'estrie le spectre de
nouvelles interdictions de voyager entre
régions ne semble pas ralentir les
québécois de toutes façons les
politiques d'annulation sont
généralement assez flexible à sur
l'industrie ici jean-sébastien cloutier
radio-canada le feu